[MUSIC PLAYING]
[APPLAUSE]
Good evening.
Welcome to this special concert
in honor of Puerto Rico.
And you just heard the fantastic
amazing son of Puerto Rico,
Miguel Zenón--
[APPLAUSE]
--and an array of soloists,
Ini Oguntola on the clarinet--
[APPLAUSE]
--Tony Terrasa on
the alto saxophone--
[APPLAUSE]
--Larry Wang and Peter
Goddard on piano--
[APPLAUSE]
--Dylan Sleeper on
tenor saxophone--
[APPLAUSE]
--Alan Osmundson
on the trumpet--
[APPLAUSE]
--and Chase [INAUDIBLE]
on the drums.
[APPLAUSE]
This is an original composition
by Miguel entitled Ceremonial.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[APPLAUSE]
Alan Osmundson on
the flugelhorn.
Miguel Zenón--
composer, saxophonist.
Part of this journey that
we're on-- as you may know,
this ensemble along with Miguel
Zenón and my amazing colleague
Evan Ziporyn, who I will
properly introduce right now--
Evan Ziporyn, bass
clarinet, other clarinets.
[APPLAUSE]
We were all slated to go to
Puerto Rico this past January.
And that wasn't possible.
But we are going January of '19.
We're going to be there.
[APPLAUSE]
And part of this journey was
an education for me, not only
about the plight of the
island, past and present,
but also getting to know
what's been going on
in our MIT community in
terms of relief and support
for Puerto Rico.
So it's been a great
pleasure to get
to know the students of the
MIT Association of Puerto Rican
Students here at MIT.
So I want to introduce you
to the president and the vice
president.
This is Gabriel Ginorio
and Nina Fraticelli-Guzmán.
Please welcome them.
[APPLAUSE]
Hello, everyone.
I hope you're feeling nice
and dry and warm in here.
I know it's a really cold night.
But it's never a bad night
to hear some good music.
Hi, I'm Nina Fraticelli.
And I am vice president of the
Association of Puerto Rican
Students.
And I'm Gabriel Ginorio.
I'm president of the MIT
Association of Puerto Rican
Students.
And we first want to thank all
the MIT festival jazz ensemble
as well as Miguel Zenón for
coming together and making this
concert.
We want to thank you all for
sharing your music with us
as well as for choosing
to have your music be
a means of bringing
support to the island
as well as raising awareness
to its current state.
Last semester, once
Hurricane Maria hit home,
APR was hard at
work to do our best
to raise awareness and
funds to help our island.
And we began by joining forces
with different universities
across the nation and started a
GoFundMe campaign that ended up
raising around $250,000.
That money was donated to
United for Puerto Rico,
an organization that helped
bring aid at critical moments
as well as donated money to
nonprofits on the island.
We then proceeded
to work on campus
and started a donation drive
that lasted three days.
And during those
three days, we were
able to see a the MIT
community's generosity
and support for us.
We ended up raising
around $6,000
that we donated to a
nonprofit on the island
and raised around four to six
pallets worth of goods ranging
from animal products to food,
canned food, and hygiene
and personal products.
And after the initial
aid phase, we now--
or some of our students
actually went back
to Puerto Rico in
January to work
on houses in the rural
part of Puerto Rico
to rebuild the roofs.
There's another group
of Puerto Rican students
that went to do field
work and research what
the lay of the land
was after the hurricane
to come back and report
to the MIT community
to figure out what
we could do later on.
There were students who
worked in the government
to try to create better digital
systems for the governor
of Puerto Rico to
be faster to respond
after natural disasters.
And ongoing, there
are various things
that the MIT community,
non-Puerto Ricans,
that our part of our
community are doing,
spring workshops and
classes, and thinking
about research
projects in the island.
And to that we helped
create a conference called
MIT Conference on the Resilient
Reconstruction of the Caribbean
that happened last December.
And we were lucky to
bring the governor
to actually speak to us and to
talk about what the issues are
on the island regarding
electricity, housing
infrastructure,
and water supply.
And people from all
around the world
and people from
the MIT community
came together to
propose solutions.
And hopefully, those
will carry on forward
with a formal MIT,
Puerto Rico, and
the Caribbean collaboration.
That's still in the works.
And we hope to be able to
announce more developments
to come.
The moral of the story here is
that Puerto Rico may be small
and in the middle of the ocean.
But we're here to support it
as best we can with our talent.
And to the future of Puerto
Rico, I say, bring it on.
And again, we want to thank
the ensemble as well as Miguel.
And we want to thank you,
the audience, for supporting.
And with that, we
want to welcome
to stage the gentleman that
helped made it possible
for us to take all our
goods to the island
and for it to reach the
people that needed it
at the most critical moments.
Please help us in welcoming
Pastor Henry Monroy.
[APPLAUSE]
Hello, everyone.
My name is Henry Monroy, a
pastor at Hyssop Christian
Church in Dorchester.
From the beginning of
this whole mission,
I was actually trying
to connect myself
with a larger organization.
Some of you guys
might know who he
is, Kurt Schilling, because
he was promoting that he
was going to help Puerto Rico.
And we started
connecting with him.
But something happened between
the process of sending things
to Puerto Rico.
Nobody was sending
nothing because there
was a miscommunication
or something
was happening within the
island that nothing was moving.
So we started raising first aid
from everyone in our church.
I was assuming that I was going
to raise probably two pallets
and probably raise $1,000
and ship it to Puerto Rico.
Within 24 hours,
our church was half
full of boxes of first aid
items, diapers, and anything
that anyone needed at the time.
That's when I started
realizing that it
was a little bit more serious.
And The Boston Globe
reached out to me.
Once that happened, I just knew
that this was going to go big.
Little by little, people
started continuing
to come to our church.
And we had different schools
and organizations reaching out
to us.
And within four to
five days, we had
to start canceling our
services because there were so
many cases of water, first
aid items in our facility
that we couldn't
have no more service.
That's when we
connected with MIT.
And it happened
through Facebook.
And then we came
and we met the group
of students that were outside
collecting other items.
And we just connected.
And I tell them, hey, whatever
it is that you guys need,
I'm here to help out.
And let's just connect
and make this happen.
So shortly after that--
yeah, that's the
team right there.
We came and pulled
up to our truck.
And we just started
filling all the stuff.
Our church is very small.
And one of our friends, he
came to the church and said,
hey, you got to be careful.
The structure of the building
might not hold all the stuff
that you have.
Yeah, that's when I
called the Boston Police.
And I asked them if they could
let us borrow their parking
lot because we had over 20
pallets of water, people
calling from New Hampshire,
Maine, all over Massachusetts.
And I just thought this was
going to be two pallets.
Surely, once I started
connecting with people,
U-Hauls were pulling
in front of the church
just unloading all the
stuff that they had.
And we just said, the doors
of the church is open.
Bring it on.
And surely, it was a lot
of stuff that we had.
But right here, we had Boston
Mothers Care, UMass Lowell,
Blue Cross Blue Shield.
And all this happened within
hours of just telling people
to help us.
And just people showed up.
It wasn't just a
Puerto Rico thing.
It wasn't just Puerto
Ricans that were coming out.
Everyone was coming out.
Everyone united, everyone
was helping us financially.
Everyone was helping
with donations.
And this is how things
get done when people unite
as one for the same cause.
And it's to help humanity out.
Sometimes we need help
from someone else.
That's why it's important to
connect with other people.
This is one of the gentlemen.
We were filling up the truck.
On Saturday, October
7, I get a phone
call at 3:00 in the morning.
So I was a little bit concerned
because there's nothing moving.
They're not accepting
nothing in the island.
And the boats-- all the
shipping companies are on hold.
At 3:00 in the morning,
I get a phone call
from a gentleman
called Roger Cruz.
He's Cuban.
And he tells me, Henry, I'm
sorry that I'm calling you
at 3:00 in the morning.
But I have an opportunity
that opened up.
And it's an overnight shipping--
a flight.
And I said, how is
this going to happen?
And he said, we have to drive
from Boston to Orlando, Florida
right now.
And I said, how are
we going to do that?
I have like over 20
pallets of water.
I have like 20 pallets of
diapers, 20 pallets of formula,
20 pallets of food.
And he said, I'm going to
rent a U-Haul in the morning.
And whatever fits
in that U-Haul,
we're taking it to Orlando.
And I said, all right.
Let's cancel our Sunday service.
And sure enough, people started
coming out within half an hour
of letting people know,
hey, we need help.
In half an hour, we
had a large group
of people just helping us out.
And within the next 24 hours,
Roger Cruz and his girlfriend,
Mari Gloria, they drove
to Orlando, Florida
and made it to FedEx.
The FAA opened up
a door of 50 tons,
a flight that would
take 24 hours basically
for it to get to Puerto Rico.
So the next day, I'm getting
a ticket to go to Puerto Rico.
And I didn't know
that I was going
to go to Puerto Rico
that next following day.
Once I get to Puerto Rico--
that's me in Carolina,
Puerto Rico with all that
stuff within 24 hours.
And the best thing
about this was
that it was completely free.
We didn't pay a dollar.
And at the end of
the whole thing,
we sent 27 pallets
without paying a dime.
And thanks to the
FAA that allowed us
to send all these things over.
This is a part of
the group that went
to the south side
of Puerto Rico.
They took 12 pallets of first
aid items to help them out.
This is pallets of baby
formula and diapers and stuff
like that that we had sent
down there to Puerto Rico.
So this is the Bank
Oriental that's
in San Juan, Puerto Rico.
I connected with a
gentleman Rauli Santos.
And within three days, we
asked Oriental, the bank,
to give us a space.
And they said, take
the whole first floor
and just put all the stuff
there and get organized.
So that's exactly what we did.
We started getting organized and
preparing packages for family.
We had over 300
packages of family
to help them for the
next four or five days.
This is the group that
Rauli Santos connected us
with in Puerto Rico.
The company that
they were working for
told them that they can work
four hours of community service
and four hours of
just regular work.
So we just took
advantage of the time.
And we just started unloading
and packing up all the stuff.
And this is us getting prepared
to go to the western side
of Puerto Rico, a good team.
And before we left, we prayed
and asked God for guidance
for this mission.
Once we arrived to the
western side of Puerto Rico--
so I just want to pause.
Mind you, I didn't
plan none of this.
I'm just in it for the ride.
So everything-- it
was like a puzzle.
And everything felt like
it went-- everything just
fell into place.
And it was just amazing.
These two gentlemen
are veterans.
They came from Texas.
They're not getting
paid for this.
They're doing this
absolutely volunteer.
And they're just
protecting us from anyone
that tried to step out
of their line I will say.
In the western side of Puerto
Rico, there was no water.
Like legitimately,
there's no water at all.
And we found this--
we found this lady
with her newborn baby.
The baby was born exactly
the same day the storm hit.
And she had no formula.
And there was no water.
Without water, you can't
mix up the formula.
So we made sure that she
had enough food and items
for the baby for the next week.
This gentleman, we found him
in Mayagüez, Puerto Rico.
Before the storm,
he had diabetes.
And his legs were amputated.
And he rode the storm
basically in his house.
The water was six feet high.
And his son was scraping
mud off the walls
while we was attending him with
veterans from Texas that also
joined us to help them out.
This gentleman, we also
met him in Mayagüez.
And he was cleaning out his car
because all the river came out.
And she was trying
to clean out his car
to make sure that it worked.
But he wouldn't be able to
move his car due to the flood.
The lady that we
helped out as well with
formula and water
for the babies.
I guess that was
number 1 thing for us
to make sure that these babies
were drinking clean water
and food.
In the south side
of Puerto Rico,
our group met with this lady.
She started crying because
nobody has helped her out
since the storm hit.
And this was one of
the pictures that
pushed me and made me realize
that we was doing a great job.
She was crying because
she hasn't drank water
in over 14 days.
And we attended her.
We helped the whole community
from the south side.
And at the end of the day, she
hugged everyone from the team
and was very happy and
excited that we weren't there.
So while this is all
happening, I just
want to inform that, in San
Juan, most of the people in San
Juan, well, they were
all right in a sense
that there was some water
but it was very limited.
Then we had to drive
2 hours and 45 minutes
to help those people that
didn't have that help.
This is the military people from
Texas that was helping us out--
great guys.
They helped us out very nice.
The sign says,
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
So basically, what it
said is, "Puerto Rico
will rise without
lights, without water,
or without communication."
That was a very powerful
statement because, at the time,
there wasn't a base where the
United States military was
taking out water and purifying
the water just for people to be
able to take a shower and
wash their clothes and dishes
and stuff like that.
So this is a military
spot as well.
This was in the--
what you see right
here in the side
where the two military
guys are freezers.
The death toll of
Puerto Rico, there
was over 1,000 people
that died in Puerto Rico.
So the building itself couldn't
hold all the bodies inside.
So the military had to
come out and place freezers
outside for the bodies.
So all these images that
I try to present here
is just to show
that it wasn't just
something that just came and
just knocked out water light.
People actually-- their
lives were really affected.
And a lot of people lost their
lives in this tragic event.
So I went to Puerto
Rico, a one-way trip.
And when our mission finished, I
said, let me go back to Boston.
I called JetBlue.
And they told me,
there's no more flights.
So I started reaching out
to every other airline.
And they're telling me, there's
no more flights till November.
So now I'm stuck in Puerto Rico.
I'm stuck in Puerto Rico now.
And I have nothing
to do because we just
finished giving everything out.
And I get a phone call
from someone on Facebook
saying that there's a doctor
that's coming from California.
At the time when
the storm happened,
there was a wildfire that
was happening in California.
And Dr. Lamaris and
Leslie reached out to us.
And they said, we have two plane
tickets to go to Puerto Rico.
We need your help.
I don't know who they are.
I said, sure come on.
And they came loaded
with medication,
things to help people out, their
diabetes, high blood pressure.
All this medication
they came with.
And we just started
helping people out.
We started going to
supermarkets in San Juan
and just getting
gallons of water
to take it to the western
side of Puerto Rico
to help more people out.
And that's us just going
door by door, reaching out
to those that can't
move, they can't
go to the hospital or the
clinics within the island.
That's me in Loiza,
Puerto Rico with the kids.
There's a lady in Loiza,
Puerto Rico as well.
She lost her whole house.
And yet she's still
living within the house.
There's no electricity.
There's no water.
And her structure is clearly--
the house was not livable.
This picture, it was
very impacting to me
because all you see is
devastation all over.
But then you see a little kid
swinging or in a playground.
That, for me, right there
represents Puerto Rico.
In the midst of a
disaster, how can you
still focus and have fun.
And that's what this
little boy was doing.
And that's why I had to
snap this picture because it
was so impacting that
I had to make sure
that I take it in image.
These are some of the doctors
as well that basically helped us
out to reach the certain
pueblos and make sure
that everybody was attended
with medication and so forth.
That's a group that went also
to the western side of Puerto
Rico with food and items
to help out others.
And that's another group
that we met in Puerto Rico.
And we went to the south side
of Puerto Rico on this occasion
to help out a school that
their whole structure was
gone in this.
So we went to Puerto
Rico in October.
We came back in December.
And we left-- in
November, I apologize.
And then went back in December
again to help out Puerto Rico.
We ended up sending
to Puerto Rico
three containers filled
with first aid items.
And it helped out
a lot of people.
A few thousand
people were helped
through the help of everyone
here in Boston, everyone
in the state of Massachusetts.
And all this could not be
done if we did not unite.
And I'm thankful for you guys.
And thank you for
this opportunity
you guys have given me.
If this was to happen--
I told this to the professor.
I feel like I'm in debt
with a lot of people
because everybody helped my
people out when they needed it.
So thank you so much,
guys, for this opportunity.
And I appreciate all you guys.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
Thank you, Henry,
for all you've done
and all you continue to do.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[APPLAUSE]
La Maga-- composition
by Miguel Zenón,
Alan Osmundson on
the flugelhorn.
Evan Ziporyn-- bass
clarinet, Evan Ziporyn.
Dylan Sleeper-- bass
flute, bass flute--
and Miguel Zenón.
We're going to do
the next two pieces
as a little set, Caravan.
And then after that, you
will hear that surprise.
This is an arrangement
by Peter Goddard
on Juan Tizol's Caravan.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[APPLAUSE]
Miguel Zenón, Evan Ziporyn--
before that Caravan, Peter
Goddard, Tony Terrasa,
Ini Oguntola.
It's been such an honor
to present this concert.
I just have a few people
to thank before we go
into the next last two pieces.
First and foremost, the students
of the MIT Festival jazz
ensemble, thank you so, so much.
[APPLAUSE]
I've known-- heard Miguel play
live for the last 13 years,
I guess, now.
And since 2013, we've been
collaborating regularly.
And it's been one of the
greatest joys of my life.
This is an amazing
musician in person.
And we're so thankful
to have him here.
[APPLAUSE]
The MIT Events
office, Cuco Daglio
on sound, Tony Debartolo
back there recording.
The people of Puerto Rico-- my
goodness, you have inspired me.
And you will continue
to inspire me.
Thank you very much.
[APPLAUSE]
For this next piece
by Miguel, Oyelo,
we're going to bring
three special guests,
all close friends and
collaborators of Miguel's.
Please welcome to the stage
David Rivera, Miguel Martinez,
and Jorge Arce.
[APPLAUSE]
While they're getting set, I
don't know if I did it or not.
But I want to
acknowledge again Evan,
who is the chair
of our department,
Evan Ziporyn, and also the head
of cast at the Center of Arts
and Science and Technology
and a world-class player
and to have this person as
a colleague year after year.
I think we collaborate
constantly because we cannot
not do that.
So it's been fantastic.
So thank you, Evan.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Ben Hart on tenor
saxophone, Dylan Sleeper
on tenor saxophone, Kevin
Costello on the trombone.
And our three percussionists
David, Miguel, Jorge.
Thank you so much, everyone.
Thank you, Fred and the band.
It's really just
a privilege always
to collaborate with
Fred and everyone
here at MIT and this
amazing group of musicians.
They've been working
hard on this music
for the past couple of months.
And it's just really inspiring
to be here and get to finally
have it played and then have you
all here to share this moment
with us is really meaningful.
So thank you so much for being
here and supporting the cause.
I really have to
acknowledge Fred's work
through all of this.
He's really been the brains
behind this whole operation.
He reached out to me, I want
to say, maybe a couple of years
ago about bringing this
band down to the island
and doing various
activities there
from concerts to
educational activities,
cultural exchanges, et cetera.
And we've been planning
this trip for a while.
Obviously, it had to be
postponed for obvious reasons.
But Fred was the
one that was really
pushing hard about having
this concert tonight.
We're going to have the same
concert in New York tomorrow.
Really more than
anything else, we're
just trying to create awareness
about the situation that's
still going on in Puerto Rico.
I mean, you saw all that
footage from earlier.
It was very, very
powerful footage.
But it's really sad to
say that that's still
going on in certain
parts of Puerto Rico.
There's folks without
water, without electricity,
without very, very
basic everyday needs.
And they really need
all the help they get.
There's a lot of stuff
going on in the world,
a lot of stuff going on in
this country, in our country,
and Puerto Rico also.
So it's easy for
this to be all news
because it happened five
months ago, six months ago.
But you should know that
it's still going on.
There's still a
lot of need there.
There's still a lot
of chaos unfortunately
going on in the island.
So we're just trying to
really create awareness
for folks like
yourselves and everyone
out there who's listening that
anything you can do to help
is greatly needed and I'm
sure is greatly appreciated
by the folks down there.
This last piece
we're going to play
is a piece I wrote
specifically for tonight.
It's the first time we've
ever played it in public.
We rehearsed it for the
last couple of days.
And I wrote this piece
thinking about various things.
One of the main things
that's happened-- it
was also already happening
before the disaster.
But especially after
the hurricanes hit,
a lot of Puerto Ricans
just started leaving
the island for obvious reasons.
Some of them, they
didn't have a home.
They needed medical help.
They needed a job.
So they started migrating to
the United States and elsewhere.
But a lot of people
did stay on the island.
And they kind of
grinded through it.
And they're still
grinding through it.
I have a lot of friends from
artists to most small business
owners who decided to stay
there and do what they could
to build that country back up.
So I wrote this piece for
them thinking about them
and thinking about the
resiliency and the courage
of a lot of those
people in Puerto Rico
and a lot of the people
who are trying to help out
the situation there.
And this one is called
En Pie de Lucha.
This is going to
close out the concert.
So thank you very much.
Thank you for your attention.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Hey!
[APPLAUSE]
Miguel Zenón.
Peter Goddard.
Puerto Rico.
MIT Festival jazz ensemble.
[APPLAUSE]